Is there harm in long-term use of apple cider vinegar?
I add one tablespoonish to my tea.
20 ounces of water.
No, so apple cider vinegar is acetic acid.
So it's a milder acid than HCl.
So what would it be the purpose of taking apple cider vinegar?
The purpose is to help acidify your stomach.
So can you take it out of empty stomach?
Yeah, you can.
Would it be maybe better for you if you take it with your meal or before meal?
It will help you break down the meal and help you digest your food.
So yes, but you can take it out of empty stomach too.
There's zero harm in taking long-term use of taking apple cider vinegar.
No, it's good for you.
The, and it's it's just go back to my blog.
Connorsledic.com look at hypochloridria.
And you'll find that the number one cause of ill health worldwide is hypochloridria,
which leads to all sorts of problems downstream years and years later, even cancer.
So anything you can do to help acidify your stomach better off you could do.
So instead of that would be just foolish things like I'm taking, you know,
high pH water, wrong.
That's just the wrong.
I take it.
I'm taking baking soda because I want to kill cancer in my breast.
Wrong.
That doesn't work that way.
All you're doing is, is alkalizing your stomach and causing more cold morbidities.
You're certainly not alkalizing the cancer by taking baking soda in your stomach,
so you actually had stomach cancer.
So, and stomach cancer is most commonly caused from H.
Pylori, which is caused from hypochloridria.
So, yeah.
So we can make mistakes.
There's a lot of ill information just completely wrong information out there.
And even practitioners that don't understand all conditions.
And, you know, want to sell you stuff and supplements.
So, yeah, you can take too many things.
I bet people come to me and they're taking 100 different supplements.
It's like, gosh.
So, yeah.
Yes, you can take too many supplements.
Yes, you can be taking the wrong thing.
And that can be too much of a good thing.
It can be a bad thing.
It's my saying.
So...